[Musique]
bonsoir messieurs andré bercoff
journaliste auteur de donald trump les
raisons de la colère comment et pourquoi
il est devenu président chez first
editions à vos côtés didier combo
spécialiste des états unis merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france alors
avant d'évoquer ce ce débat sur cette
censure hein
peut-on appeler ça on va on va
d'ailleurs en débattre ensemble est-ce
qu'on peut prononcer le mot de censure
je voulais aborder avec vous une
information qui est tombée en fin de
journée un cette résolution qui va
passer au vote et qui marquera
l'ouverture formelle de là nestea d'une
tentative en tout cas de destitution
contre trump à ce que ce n'est pas un
petit peu trop tard andré bercoff c'est
un symbole en tout cas moi écouter c'est
exactement les les démocrates en fait tu
voudrais que trump
pour eux c'est pire que ben laden c'est
à dire que ce qu'il souhaite c'est qu'il
soit un jour je tue et jetés en mer et
surtout qu'on ne qu'il disparaisse au
l'entente plus parler de lui
il y a quand même cette espèce de ça
fait quand même totalement aller je
dirais tragique au comique en fait sur
n'ai pas envie de vraiment de deux de
rire avec avec cette espèce de il est à
huit jours de 2,2 de son départ et au
fait une procédure de destitution
alors soit disant pour l'empêcher de
revenir en 2024
il y a une espèce vous savez c'est à la
mesure cette frénésie est à la mesure de
la peur panique a eu pendant quatre ans
n'oubliez jamais que trappe et télé sur
pattes heures c'était quelqu'un qui va
surtout ne devait pas le président de la
république et ils ont les aurons il a
été président contre toute attente en
2016 et il fallait surtout pas que la
catastrophe je part en vrille mais pour
un certain nombre de gens se renouvelle
et on a tout fait pour ça et là on sent
avec ce que vous avez dit sur les gars
phare avec n'est même pas la censure
fait ça va beaucoup plus loin
quoi avec l'ordre règne à varsovie on ne
veut plus voir une tête qui passe et
surtout pas celle de trump très
franchement si ce n'était pas aussi
tragique pour ceux qui montrent ce que
montrent les ats-unis le fossé ce serait
assez dérisoire didier concours
parallèle à nancy pelosi et présenter un
ultimatum à malpensa dimanche activé en
urgence le 25e amendement qui consiste à
constater l'inaptitude du président
exercer sa fonction un républicain s'est
opposé aujourd'hui à son adoption
immédiate à l'unanimité que cherche à
faire les démocrates puisque de toute
façon donald trump va s'en aller avec
toutes les critiques et un qui entourent
le président sortant aujourd'hui il ya
donc quel est le but finalement
m'écouter étant donné ce qui s'est passé
au capitole bien entendu là la classe
politique doit doit réagir à cela mais
l'objectif d'aider des démocrates idée
double comme le disait andré bercoff ils
ont comme objectif de rendre trump
inéligible en vue de 2024 mais ils ont
aussi relogés ctif d'introduire un coin
au sein du parti républicain pour
essayer de de séparer les soutiens de
trump des républicains modérés qui
commence à être un petit peu embarrassé
par trump en quelque sorte et c'est
certainement la raison pour laquelle
nancy pelosi a lancé un ultimatum à
peines pour faire jouer le 25e
amendement ce qui serait
institutionnellement très difficile
façon alors les démocrates mettent en
avant je cite un président déranger une
menace imminente contre la démocratie
américaine
trump pour l' aime ou on aime pas il a
tout de même un bilan parce que ça
semblait être éludée aujourd'hui andré
bercoff vous l'expliquez comment cette
haine
en titre up aujourd'hui il s'est tiré
une balle dans le pied lui même le
président sortant avec ces images
catastrophiques au capitole écoutez
l'image du libyen jusqu'à saint sophie
du capitole certes ma faim ça n'a pas
été la prise du palais d'hiver ni la
prise de la bastille
je crois que vraiment il faut il faut
relativiser tout ça je crois que tous
les moyens étaient bons pour se
débarrasser notre oeuvre
trump ne l'oublient pas son bilan quand
même vois pas faire tout son bilan
inverse sur le chômage sur le pouvoir
d'achat et caetera et même sur les
vaccins il faut pas oublier que si
pfizer a pu faire ça c'est que trump a
injecté et même les les adversaires les
plus résolus trompeuses à injecter des
milliards de dollars fédéraux dans le
et puis parlons pas de politique
étrangère parlons pas tout le reste
franchement que trump aujourd'hui il y a
eu ses assistants du capitole mais que
tout le reste disparaissent au profit de
voir à l'espèce de charlatans fou et
quand même une d'une dérision
fantastique et je rejoins
l'interlocuteur en disant que
effectivement ce qui va se passer c'est
ça le plus grave c'est que les
démocrates ne voient pas qu'ils
introduisent avec ça une division
terrible en amérique je crois que
vraiment on va entendre beaucoup parler
dans les prochains mois au delà
évidemment de la personne de trump de
ses 75 millions d'américains qu'ils aux
antilles gruger de cette élection et les
autres si vous voulez du côté démocrate
vous allez avoir les le gauche du parti
démocrate représenté par kamala harris
la vice présidente qui va jouer un rôle
très important donc on va véritablement
et on le voit déjà avec cette espèce
d'extra la pression de toutes les
censures un pas seulement les gars fars
je vous signale quelque chose qui vient
de se passer il y avait des partisans de
trump vous savez après le capitole qui
sont restés de toi george washington qui
sont rentrés et bien l'une des
compagnies aériennes a refusé de les
prendre
parce qu'il est né vous est sur la liste
des terroristes
c'est à dire qu'il y a quelque chose
nous complètement irrationnel là dedans
et vraiment il faudra faire très
attention tout
l'amérique parce que ça risque de donner
dela lendemain qui déchante très fort
alors destitution ou par les réseaux
sociaux n'ont pas attendu un pour clouer
le bec à au président sortant ils ont
pris la décision seul a commencé par
twitter écouter
après un examen attentif des tweets
récents du conte real donald trump et le
contexte qui les entoure nous avons
suspendu définitivement le compte en
raison du risque de nouvelles
incitations à la violence
didier combo est ce qu'ils ont eu raison
d'aller jusque là fermeture définitive
du compte 80 mille abonnés on la paie
cash 1 million par blonde abonnés on le
rappelle ces femmes c'est
contre-productif ces six parce que le
les conspirationnistes qui soutiennent
treuil 10 prétendre prétendent apporter
les informations qui sont cachés par
l'establishment donc si on leur coupe
leurs moyens de communication il le rend
que plus raison de dire ça et puis bien
évidemment ça pose un problème puisque
trump puisque twitter est une entreprise
privée et c'est donc une entreprise
privée qui va censurer non pas des
propos d'ailleurs mais censuré une
personne puisque il ne s'agit pas
d'effacer telle ou telle fuite de train
il s'agit de lui interdire l'accès à
twitter et ça à mon avis c'est
contreproductif il part et puis d'autre
part ça pose le problème de savoir si
une entreprise privée est légitime à
faire cette chose là et de surcroît il
ne faut pas oublier que les manades la
silicon valley sont des soutiens de
démocrates donc c'est d'autant plus
gênant kill kill kill 1 qui ferme ce
conte de tron
et c'est d'autant plus sujet à critique
alors via twitter n'est pas le seul à
annoncer la suspension par 90 du comte
de donald trump
regardez c'est impressionnant le nombre
plateforme qui ont banni le président
sortant pertinentes ou non la décision
de censurer un président en exercice
peut-elle être décidée par une
entreprise sans contrôle légitime et
démocratique
la suspension du compte de trump la
purge des géants du numérique contre ses
partisans devrait indigner tout citoyen
attaché à la démocratie
où s'arrêtera ce contrôle de toutes
opinions dissidentes qui demain sera
effacée numériquement sans possibilité
de se défendre
trump c'est pas ma tasse de thé mais la
fermeture désormais définitive de son
compte par twitter me paraît scandaleuse
doit-on délégué notre liberté
d'expression au géant de la silicon
valley demain ce sera pour nous tous
cette censure numérique et privés la
fermeture du compte de donald trump art
witter si elle peut se justifier par une
forme de prophylaxie d'urgence n'en pose
pas moins des questions fondamentales la
régulation du débat public par les
principaux réseaux sociaux au regard de
leurs seules conditions générales
d'utilisation
alors qu'ils sont devenus de véritables
espaces publics et rassemble des
milliards de citoyens
cela semble pour le moins un peu court
d'un point de vue démocratique au delà
de la haine en ligne et nous avons
besoin d'inventer une nouvelle forme de
supervision démocratique
le comportement de trump ne peut servir
de prétexte pour que les gars face à
roye le pouvoir de contrôler le débat
public
les lois macro ont pourtant légalisé
cette censure privé alors là on vient de
voir effectivement les réactions
politiques nombreuses aujourd'hui après
ce bannissement de donald trump des
réseaux sociaux je vous parlais des
plates formes à on les voit enfin
apparaître un oeil en restera au banni
le président trump
on le voit on ne s'attendait pas
forcément entendre quelqu'un comme jean
luc mélenchon défendre donald trump et
pourtant jusqu'à une gueule à merkel qui
a trouvé que cela posé problème
vous comprenez villiers combo qu'en
france finalement on s'étonne de cette
forme si j'ose dire de censure oui tout
à fait et comme religieuse qui est
ce qui est étonnant ce qui est peut-être
assurant d'une certaine manière c'est
que cette indignation
on la voit sur tout le spectre politique
donc il y a effectivement un problème
c'est un problème qui est extrêmement
difficile à résoudre parce que c'est
plate forme ne sont pas des éditeurs ne
sont pas les journaux un journal peut
choisir de publier ou ne pas publier
telle personne mais ces réseaux sociaux
c'est l'équivalent des fabricants de
papier en quelque sorte c'est le moyen
et ils n'ont pas de responsabilité
éditoriale d'ailleurs meyers en cause un
problème parce que les ils ne sont pas
considérés comme des des médias
ordinaire aux etats unis ils ne peuvent
pas être tenus pour responsables de ce
qui est posté sur leur plateforme
mais d'un autre côté si ils censurent
quelqu'un alors à ce moment-là ils
agissent comme des journaux et comme des
éditeurs est donc là ici une tension
entre entre ces deux points et qui est
en train de faire débat aux états unis
andré berlocq ce sont clairement les
gaffes à aujourd'hui qui décident type
qu'on doit prendre la parole au nom
écoutez ça va beaucoup plus loin moi je
vais vous dire quelque chose je pense
que pinochet est aujourd'hui à la
silicon valley faut le dire s'installe
si on ne fait pas attention une
véritable dictature de la parole une
dictature qui va peser au lieu la de
l'histoire de trump on ne peut pas
laisser parce que ce n'est pas pour
l'américain c'est un problème français
c'est un problème mondial ça problème
évidemment européen on ne peut pas
laisser des genres ddd quelques
multimilliardaire ils sont cinq
multimilliardaire régenter de la planète
et régenter la liberté d'expression le
phénomène les points est très grave
c'est beaucoup plus grave que ce qui
s'est passé au capitole ou ailleurs
c'est iil ont profité de quelque chose
l'incendié du reichstag ne pas faire
toutes comparaisons historiques
ce serait malvenu mais je veux dire
qu'il y a quelque chose de grave
aujourd'hui dans le fait que quelques
personnes je lis bien quelques personnes
parce qu'on les a laissés de venir
les monopoles les légats fans peuvent
régenter véritablement les paroles de
tout le monde je crois que pour moi
c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
grave
et justement quand on parle de fascisme
pour les avants de qui et de quoi on
parle
merci en tout cas tous les deux andré
bercoff didier combo d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france